(intro music)
- Welcome back everybody.
When a feel good story
goes viral on social media
I scoop it up and present it here.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
Okay, so I wasn't aware of this
but apparently some people
leave their favorite recipe
on their tombstone when they pass away.
Did you know this? I didn't know this.
Oh, you did know... Fine, you're that guy.
But the recipes could be for anything.
Their favorite brownie,
fudge, maybe a cookie.
And get this, a woman on TikTok
is hunting these recipes down
and cooking all of them.
Her name is Rosie and she's from here
in Southern California, where she watches
on NBC four, Los Angeles at three.
She's on the line right now.
What's up, Rosie?
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Hi.
- Hello.
- So how did you learn about this?
I've never heard that people
leave recipes on their tombstones.
- Oh gosh. It's been a journey.
So, I am a digital librarian,
and I was in library science school
at the University of Maryland.
I had to take a class on social networks
and basically make a TikTok
from scratch for the class.
And at the same time I was interning
at Congressional Cemetery.
And so my professor was like,
"You should make a TikTok
about your internship."
So I started posting about gravestones
and cemetery life and,
cemetery life, (laughs)
and things like that.
And through that process
I was also starting
to cook for the first time.
It was during the pandemic.
I never really cooked before.
And then all in this process together
I first found this gravestone
for Naomi Miller Dawson,
she's in Brooklyn, New York,
and she has this beautiful gravestone
with a spritz cookie on it.
And she doesn't just say
that she likes cookies,
like it has the ingredients listed out.
So I cooked it, I posted it on TikTok
and it exploded in this way
I never would've expected.
- It's super cool and so personal,
like to put on your tombstone.
And people are known for like, you know,
something they make.
It's really special.
I'd never heard of it.
So, what's one of your
favorite recipes you found?
- Oh my gosh. All of them are so good.
They're all, they're all desserts
but they're all very
different from each other.
Very connected to the
the person buried there.
But my favorite right now is
this Snicker doodle cookie.
I actually made a plate for it right now.
They're Annabell's Snicker doodles.
Annabell Gunderson,
she's buried in Willits, California.
She was a grandmother. She loved Alaska.
She went there 30 times in life.
She worked as a bookkeeper
in her local school.
And these cookies are so good.
They also make quite a lot,
they're like good for a family gathering.
- Okay. Okay. Well we
have some snicker doodles
cause I didn't wanna be disrespectful.
(audience clapping and cheering)
So, I'm gonna try one.
Here we go.
Oh, look at that, they do make a lot.
Okay.
- Yeah, it makes so many,
but they're so good.
Now let's try it.
- This is amazing.
This is actually my
mother's favorite cookie
is a snicker doodle cookie.
So thank you for this recipe.
(audience clapping and cheering)
I'm liking your post right now, okay.
And that's not all. Our
season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of friction,
the go to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
and just having cool
thoughts just like you.
So, they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience clapping and cheering)
(laughing)
All right, thank you so much Rosie.
And thank you to all our guests today.
Margaret Cho, Stephanie
Larson, Angel, Don,
and Richard Marks and his sons.
Y'all have a great day and
if it's not (indistinct).
(audience clapping and cheering)